dans un nicolas pernikoff vous avez été
mon patron nicolas oui vous savez que
c'est drôle de voir tous les deux parce
que moi j'ai une anecdote si je peux me
permettre d'en parler c'est que michel
s'est engueulé plein de gens de ce
métier à cause de vous oui ça va
vous savez ça ou par michel tu dois en
parler oui bien sûr qu'est ce que j'ai
pu m'engueuler à cause de lui comment tu
peux supporter ce mec
comment tu peux hanouna écoute
franchement il haïra il frappa trois
mois gilles va faire 20 ans dans la jet
d'affairé en hausse de 15,7 et à chaque
fois je me bats ta maison vous rendez
pas compte
vous rendez pas compte que c'est que
chad indirects ou les soins que vous
l'aimez vous l'aimez pas c'est un autre
problème qui soit clivant hop
actuellement c'est pas le problème lui
de chavannes nous quand on a fait lui
adrien les gens nîmes vous n'imaginez
pas ce que c'est que faire une
quotidienne en direct tous les soirs qui
se termine à 20h 20h15 20h30 22h23 enfin
syrie ni les gens se rendent pas compte
que c'est comme effort surtout tous les
jours c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé pour toi de respect même si de
temps en temps
[Applaudissements]
j'ai même dit un jour à des confrères je
dis non seulement vous trompez vous
allez voir qu'un jour les politiques
viendront chez vue et michel drucker il
a vu tout le monde il connaît tout le
monde il a fait 57 rentrée sur les 57
ans si je vous demande de repartir dans
une décennie ou dans une émission vous
avez aimé la vous repartez en quelle
année et sur quelle émission c'est quoi
le truc que vous êtes senti le plus
heureux dans votre vie où vous ai dis là
vraiment je suis heureuse je kiffe ben
ma première finale de coupe du monde
entre le brésil et l'italie au stade
aztèque en 70 les adieux de l'est
j'étais le plus jeune commentateur de la
planète
je m'en passe pas à chaque fois j'ai
commenté pour les pays francophones pour
l'afrique
les adieux de pelé pour un gamin qui
rêvait d'être joueur de foot comme moi
ou commentateurs vous imaginez ce que
c'est et puis surtout on est devenus
copains avec pelé bien jour il est venu
à paris il m'a offert les chaussures de
sa finale que je veux faire un enfant
handicapé
donc ça c'est un grand moment mais je
dois dire que il ya eu des moments très
émouvants et aussi très drôle